était-ce un rêve
le garçon cligna à nouveau des yeux
au-dessus du tourne-disque apparut
vivement un arc de lumière colorée
il se creusa comme un fantôme il brillait et
pulsait
il pompait comme un cœur rempli de sang il
sursautait et tremblait comme un stop-motion
regarde ça dis
quoi
oh ouais
mec je parie que tu ne savais pas ce qui était
mieux pour toi
car je le fais pour le côté droit ne l'ai-je pas
fait pour le côté gauche
tous ensemble au milieu ouais laisse-moi
le ramener un peu
les écouteurs portent le groove  l'électricité
vous bougez sagement et les amplis portent le groove
marié à bouger en tombant dans le ciel
avec quelques sons montez-le pendant une seconde
et baissez-le donnez-le-moi un autre
boom record
comme
l'homme de l'électricité je parie que vous ne saviez pas que c'était mieux
pour votre
élévation comment nous le faisons avec la confiture votre
chemise votre souffle obtenez votre peau un peu
humide
les mains si vous avez vu beaucoup de terre
gardez vos bras levés s'il vous plaît développez
avec votre plante l'infâme est xavier
l'école et le blaster plus rapide  quand je
prends le contrôle de ton château, toutes les femmes du roi
et tous les hommes du roi ne pouvaient pas remettre
le son avec l'
innocent une victoire de club arrière est comme un
x-men de Worthington et des choses comme une
grenade à main allume un bâton de dynamite et
pose  en bas dans la baie mettez-le dans votre bouche
éduquez votre tête est-ce graphique comme un
animal dans la circulation tuer au bord de la route quand j'active
la compétence tous mes bpm sont
comme ça
regarde maintenant
oh ouais